So the trick for doing algorithms like
Value Iteration in infinite state space
like what you get from the belief MDP is
going to come only by looking really,
really, really carefully
at the infinite case and
then showing that we can be
represented in a finite way.
So what we're going to do now
is actually step through what
Value Iteration would
look like in POMDPS.
And then piece by piece,
we're going to convert that to something
that actually can be computed.
So at first, it's going to be math and
then it's going to be an algorithm.
So here's Value Iteration written
out and it's in POMDPS but
sort of doesn't really matter yet.
We're going to define the value
function at step zero,
as a function of the belief,
to just be zero everywhere.
And then we'll say, for t greater than
zero, the value function for time stamp
t as a function of belief state b,
is going to be the max overall actions,
the reward for taking that action in
the context of that belief state.
Plus the discounted expected
value of where we end up right so
that we're going to observe
is an observation z.
And so we're going to let sum over
all the possible observations
the probability that we make that
observation times the value function
at the previous time step for
the resulting belief state b prime,
which is the what we get by doing
what we talked about on the previous
slide which we call the state
estimation for b, a, z.
>> All right, that seems reasonable.
I mean other than the fact that
r is not a function of b and
a that just it means
the reward you actually got.
Right so let's, what is this, what
is this like, what is the reward for
being being in the belief state b given
that we take action a, how can we
represent that in terms of quantities
that we're more familiar with?
>> By unrolling probabilities or
something the same way we did last time.
Yeah and in particular all we have to
do is say well you know we would get
the reward for
state s we were in state s.
So let's just sum overall states the
probability we're actually in that state
the reward that we would
get from that state and
of course this is just the belief
state for for state s.
So this is really just the dot product
of the belief state with kind of
a vector that you could make out
of the rewards for a given action.
>> So, it really is just the the average
award you expect given the belief state.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> And so again now that we've
got that out of the way,
the scary thing here is this function
v this value function is defined over
an infinite set of belief states, these
vectors of probabilities over states.
So again we're not going to let
that scare us quite yet, but
it is something we have to keep in mind.
Otherwise, we could just
implement this directly.
All we would need is
a loop that would say for
all belief states do this update.
It's just that there's
an infinite number of them so
that would not terminate
>> Yeah but
you could write it in really
just a few lines of code.
>> [LAUGH] Yes, you could write an
infinite loop in very few lines of code.
>> Beautiful really.
>> This is how we're going to jump from
the infinite to the finite is we have,
we're going to make a claim.
And the claim goes like this, that for
all t, the value function times steps t,
over all belief states b,
right so this is over
the infinite set of possible belief
states, can be written in a finite way.
In particular, the maximum over
some set of vectors gamma sub t that
we're going to have to deal with later.
But the point is that it's
a finite set of vectors.
The maximum of the dot product of
the vectors in that set
with the belief state.
>> Okay.
>> Where
a dot product is really just
the sum over all the states,
the weighted probability being
that state times this alpha of s.
So this kind of function is sometimes
called piecewise linear and
convex and the reason is, that if we
actually, if we think about belief space
as being well it's just a really
simple one, like the space of
probability distributions over
just the two possible states.
So we have some probability
between zero and one and
if probability one represents we're
totally definitely in state S1
otherwise if the probably zero,
were totally definitely in state S0 and
in between where in between there some
probability of S series some probably
of S1, In the halfway in
between would be half of each.
Okay?
So what
functions of this kind have in common
is that each of these alpha times b
is a linear function
of the belief state.
All right?
So
each of that alphas in
the set capital gamma sub t
is some linear function of the belief
state and what we're going
to do is we have a whole bunch of them
at any given belief state b what we're
doing is we're taking the maximum value
of all these possible linear functions.
So at the end of the day the actual
function that we've represented
is this upper surface of
these linear functions
each of which is defined
in the set capital gamma.
Does that make some sense?
>> Sure, makes me think of something
you did in the last class.
>> What was that?
>> Well,
when we did the game theory stuff.
Remember that?
>> Yes, so right,
so maximums over linear functions
comes up in game theory as well.
Yeah, it's a good point.
>> And there they end up
looking very piecewise linear.
>> Yep, and convex, right?
They open upwards to the top.
And that's because of the max and
the piece has linears because it's
a finite set of linear functions.